aquí tenemos una pintura de rené
descartes una de las mentes más
brillantes tanto en matemáticas como en
filosofía porque esto era algo bastante
común que grandes filósofos también eran
grandes matemáticos y viceversa de
alguna manera era contemporáneo de
galileo era 32 años menor que galileo
aunque murió poquito después que galileo
este cuate murió joven galileo ya era
mayor de 70 años mientras que descartes
murió a tan sólo 54 años de edad
descartes es más conocido en la cultura
popular por esta cita que tenemos aquí
una cita filosófica pienso luego existo
pero también quería mostrarte y esto no
tiene que ver con álgebra pero es una
cita muy precisa quizás la menos
conocida de sus citas esta que tenemos
aquí y yo pienso que es muy práctica y
te hace darte cuenta que estas grandes
mentes estos pilares de la filosofía las
matemáticas al final de cuentas eran
simples seres humanos y dice tan solo
sigue intentando tan solo sigue
intentando incurrir todos los errores
posibles simplemente seguir intentando
pienso que este es un gran consejo para
la vida
él hizo muchas cosas en filosofía y
matemáticas pero la razón por la cual lo
estoy incluyendo aquí en esta
fundamentación del álgebra que estamos
haciendo es que él es el responsable
directo de ese fuerte vínculo que se
establece entre el álgebra y la
geometría aquí tenemos de nueva cuenta
la palabra álgebra hemos platicado
acerca de ella tenemos ecuaciones que se
establecen con símbolos símbolos que
básicamente toman valores si tenemos por
ejemplo algo como ye igual a 2 x menos 1
esto establece una relación entre
cualquier cosa que represente x y
cualquier cosa que represente que
podemos de hecho construir una tabla
aquí tomar valores de x y ver cuáles son
los valores de ye correspondientes
podría tomar valores aleatorios de xy
calcular cuál es el valor de y pero va a
tomar valores que son relativamente
simples y comunes para que las
matemáticas no se compliquen así por
ejemplo si x es igual a menos 2 que es
igual a 2 x menos 2 menos 12 x menos 2 -
1 y esto es igual 2 x menos 2 es menos 4
menos uno es igual a menos 5
ahora x igual a menos 1 lleva a ser
igual a 2 por menos 1 menos 12 por menos
12 y menos 1 esto es igual a menos 3 si
x es igual a 0 y es igual a 2 por 0 - 1
2 por 0 es cero menos uno esto es igual
a menos uno puede ser un par más si x es
igual a uno y puedo tomar cualesquiera
valores aquí puedo ver qué pasa si x es
igual a menos la raíz cuadrada de 2 o
qué pasa si x es igual a menos 5 medios
o 6 séptimos sin embargo estoy tomando
estos valores que facilitan el cálculo
del valor de y entonces cuando x es
igual a 1 lleva a ser igual a dos por
uno menos uno
esto es igual 2 por 12 menos uno es
igual a 1 voy a hacer un último valor
voy a hacerlo en otro color aquí tenemos
el púrpura que no usado aún entonces
cuando x es igual a 2 que va a ser igual
a 2 x 2 menos 12 por 2 es igual a 4
menos uno esto es igual a 3 suficiente
por así decirlo saque muestras de esta
relación
por un lado aquí se describe una
relación general entre una variable y y
una variable x y simplemente la hice más
concreta dije ok si x es una de estas
variables para cada uno de los valores
de x cuál sería el valor correspondiente
de iu y descartes se dio cuenta que
podías visualizar esto por un lado
puedes visualizar estos puntos
individuales y eso te va a ayudar en
general a visualizar esta relación
básicamente lo que hizo fue establecer
un puente entre el mundo abstracto del
álgebra simbólica y el mundo de la
geometría que tiene que ver con formas
dimensiones y ángulos entonces aquí
tenemos la palabra geometría y
obviamente hay gente en la historia
quizás mucha gente cuya historia se ha
olvidado gente que pudo haber
incursionado en esto pero antes de
descartes la visión general que se tenía
de la geometría era la de la geometría
euclidiana la cual básicamente la
geometría que estudiaste en las clases
de geometría de secundaria y
preparatoria
esa geometría que estudia las relaciones
entre triángulos y sus ángulos las
relaciones que se encuentran entre los
círculos y sus radios y aquellas que se
establecen entre los triángulos
inscritos en círculos ya profundizaremos
sobre esto en la lista de geometría así
que descartes dijo bueno yo creo que
puedo representar esto visualmente de la
misma manera que euclides estudios de
ángulos y estos círculos y se dijo que
tal si consideramos un pedazo de papel
pensemos en dos dimensiones ese pedazo
de papel puedes considerarlo como una
sección de dos dimensiones las llamamos
dos dimensiones porque tenemos la
dirección que va de arriba hacia abajo
déjame hacerlo en azul
estamos tratando de visualizar cosas así
es que usar el color de la geometría
entonces es la dimensión que va de
arriba hacia abajo y también tenemos la
dimensión que va de izquierda a derecha
por eso lo llamamos el plano
bidimensional si estudiamos usando tres
dimensiones tendríamos la dimensión que
va de adentro hacia afuera es muy fácil
trabajar en dos dimensiones en la
pantalla pues la pantalla es
bidimensional y se dijo bien aquí
tenemos dos varias
que tienen esta relación porque no
asociamos cada una de estas variables
con cada una de las dimensiones aquí y
por convención hagamos esta la variable
y que realmente en la variable
dependiente la manera como la
construimos depende de lo que es x
pongamos entonces es en el eje vertical
y pongamos nuestra variable
independiente aquella en la cual tomamos
valores aleatorios para obtener el valor
de y pongamos está en el eje horizontal
de hecho fue descartes quien propuso la
convención de usar x que es y como
veremos posteriormente zetas propuso
esto para el álgebra para designar las
incógnitas o las variables que estamos
manipulando y se dijo si lo vemos de
esta manera sin numerados estas
dimensiones así tomemos entonces en la
dirección x menos 3
luego aquí tenemos menos 2 menos 10
simplemente estoy enumerando la
dirección x la que va de izquierda a
derecha
este es entonces uno este es dos este
estrés lo mismo vamos a hacer para la
dirección y aquí tenemos menos 5
- 4 - 3
de hecho déjame hacerlo más claro deja
de borrarle aquí un poco luego a borrar
para que podamos extendernos y así
podamos llegar hasta el -5 sin que se
vea muy desordenado bajemos todo esto
para poder numerar lo entonces tenemos 1
2 3
aquí tenemos menos uno menos dos y estas
son simplemente convenciones podemos
poner el eje x aquí el iac y tomar los
positivos del lado izquierdo los
negativos del lado derecho en fin son
convenciones desde la época de descartes
sigamos - 3 - 4 - 5 él dijo bueno yo
creo que pueda asociar cada pareja de
valores con un punto en el plano
bidimensional puedo tomar la coordenada
en x el valor de x por ejemplo el valor
de menos 2 es menos 2 hacia la izquierda
en este eje que va de izquierda a
derecha es hacia la izquierda pues es
negativo y está asociado con menos 5
menos 5 hacia abajo en el eje vertical
decimos que el valor de 10 menos
así es que si vamos 2 hacia la izquierda
y 5 abajo
obtenemos este punto de aquí así que lo
que dijo estos dos valores de menos 2 y
menos 5 los puedo asociar con este punto
aquí en el plano bidimensional así que
decimos este punto de aquí tiene las
coordenadas que me indican cómo
encontrar el punto menos 2 menos 5 estas
coordenadas son conocidas como
coordenadas cartesianas en honor
precisamente a rené descartes porque fue
él quien las introdujo el tuvo la idea
de asociar estas relaciones con puntos
en un plano coordenada y entonces dijo
hagamos otra relación
aquí tenemos otra relación cuando x es
igual a menos uno cuando x es igual a
menos uno y es igual a menos tres así
que x es menos uno y menos tres es este
punto de aquí y la convención es cuando
escribe las coordenadas primero escribes
la coordenada en x y luego la coordenada
en que eso es lo convenido menos uno
como menos tres el punto que tenemos
aquí y luego tenemos el punto cuando x
vale cero y lleva al menos uno cuando x
vale cero aquí lo tenemos significa que
no te mueves ni a la izquierda
a la derecha que es menos 11 hacia abajo
aquí tenemos el punto cero coma menos
uno ahí tenemos este punto y así
seguimos el punto 1 1 1 para x 1 para y
aquí lo tenemos el punto 2 3 2 para x 3
para ayer
de hecho déjame hacerlo en el mismo
color púrpura 2 para x 3 para y es el
punto 2,3 de que lo va a poner también
de naranja el punto 1,1 esto ya es
estupendo en sí lo que hice básicamente
fue tomar valores arbitrarios de x pero
lo que él se dio cuenta es que si tú
tomas valores otros valores de xy toal
valores de x entre estos que ya tomé al
final de cuentas tendrás la gráfica de
una recta así que si tú pudieras tomar
todos los valores posibles de x
terminarías con la gráfica de una recta
parecida a ésta la gráfica de una recta
como ésta que tenemos aquí y cualquier
relación si tú tomas cualquier equis y
encuentras la aie correspondiente
representa en realidad un punto sobre
esta línea otra manera de ver esto es
que cualquier punto sobre esta recta
representa una solución a este
que tenemos aquí así si tenemos este
punto de aquí en el cual parece que x es
uno y medio y es igual a dos déjame
escribir eso 1.52 s es una solución de
esta ecuación cuando x es 1.5 2 x 1.5 es
3 - 1 es 2 vemos que se cumple la
ecuación así de repente él fue capaz de
construir un puente sobre este hueco
estableciendo la relación entre álgebra
y geometría podemos ahora visualizar
todas las parejas de xy que satisfacen
esta ecuación que tenemos aquí así que
él es el responsable de hacer este
puente y es por eso que las coordenadas
que usamos para especificar estos puntos
se llaman coordenadas cartesianas y como
veremos el primer tipo de ecuaciones que
se estudian son ecuaciones como estas
que en un curso tradicional de álgebra
se llaman ecuaciones lineales ecuaciones
lineales y podrías pensar bueno veo que
esto es una ecuación igual a algo con x
pero que tiene esto de lineal que es lo
que hace que se vean como una línea para
darse cuenta porque es lineal tienes que
dar el brinco que dio rené descartes
porque si gráficas esto usando
coordenadas cartesianas sobre un plano
clidia no vas a obtener una línea recta
y próximamente verás que existen otro
tipo de ecuaciones donde no tienes una
línea recta obtienes una curva o figuras
locas y extrañas